now the
[Music]
the fact that they've been blindly
deceived
don't you come here and say
and
[Music]
is
what to do
[Music]
it will lead you back
me
oh
faster
astrid
the joker seems about right
feels like another record cold snap on
the way
i better get a fire going before the
pipes freeze up again
ah a rare mckenzie family photo
miss you dad
great bear island dad used to fly there
all the time
he said it used to be beautiful not much
reason to go there these days
since the quakes and all
well here we are old girl
your best flights may be behind you but
you're still beautiful to me
and anyways you're all i've got
i'd sure love to give you one last great
adventure
i don't remember needing my parka this
early in the season
it seems to get colder every year
jackrabbit remote transport zero flights
a day to the mainland communities
well anywhere really
cheap electric crap never works when you
need it
damn i was right pipes froze up again
those were better days
that's done
getting pretty late in the day guess i
could
take a nap
who could that be
jackrabbit remote transport mackenzie
speaking i told her not to come up
i told her you couldn't fly in this
weather for once will you
not be so damned whoa well slow down
maureen what are you talking
[Music]
uh
hello will
[Music]
what are you doing here it's been a
while i know
yeah years
i haven't heard from you since i know i
know
and i wouldn't be here if it weren't
important well
what brings you i mean
are you sick no no not me
but i need to get to someone who is
right so you're still a doctor
yes i'm still a doctor i thought that
after
why are you here i need your help
there's an isolated community in the
northern part of great bear
someone there is very sick great bear
there's nothing there anymore
not since i know but i have to get there
still trying to save the world huh
somebody has to what's that supposed to
mean
mackenzie will
i didn't come here to fight about the
past i need a pilot to take me somewhere
remote
someone who won't ask too many questions
someone i can trust wait questions
astrid are you in trouble are you gonna
help me
or not what's in the case
see there's that thing about no
questions remember what's in the case
astrid
no questions
look the weather out there is bad
bad but it's getting worse you walk in
here after
years i could have been dead you could
have been
then you show up and you want me to just
risk my life flying into the middle of
the great northern nowhere to deliver
you and some mystery metal case to some
remote wilderness outpost all because
you walked in here and asked me to
yes astrid
you can't bring him back this isn't
about that
i know how hard it's been no
you don't know mackenzie you don't know
anything you don't think i feel it too
are you gonna take me or not
the longer i wait the worse it'll get
damn it i don't have time for this wait
the worse what we'll get why do i have a
feeling you're not talking about the
weather
because i'm not
throw your bags in the plane i'll get
started on pre-flight
better buckle up tight because it's
going to be a rough ride
let's see two people plus enough fuel to
get us out to great bare and back leaves
almost no capacity for cargo
if we're too heavy we'll burn through
our fuel before we get there
i'll have to be careful about what else
i take with me
uh
astrid's traveling pretty light wherever
she's going
the mysterious case asper definitely
doesn't want to talk about what's inside
just need to grab my parka and we can go
oh yeah i mean
i just forgot to take it off
i wear mine too why
memories i guess i thought you wanted to
forget
not all of it
look i i should have looked for you
it's okay i've kept busy
i've moved on you sure
because this all seems pretty familiar
you still working with that researcher
doctor what's his name
no no i'm not working at the center
anymore
well then where i'm working on my own
freelance you could say freelance doctor
sounds legit
i don't question your life choices
mackenzie
plenty of things you could be doing
besides hanging out in your dad's old
plane and just
drinking in the daytime hey we had a lot
of good times in this plane
and it's under control i know okay i'm
not here to fight
really
i think about them all the time you know
i know you do
what i did a choice i made
i did it for us you don't have to
that's just not it's important that you
hear this
there's things i need to see not now
there's just let me tell you well
shut up for a second something's wrong
[Music]
that is not good what's going on
whole electrical system looks fried [ __ ]
what's happening no power means we're
going down
hold tight
well
[Music]
astrid
ah
[Music]
astrid
must have gone right through the
windshield
trees broke my fall oh
mostly
[Music]
you